Remember the goal is performance efficient implementation of RVM.
The restricted semantics of transaction help a lot in making sure
that what we are designing as a reliable virtual memory is
not very heavyweight. But the implementation of that
used semantic, as to be efficient as well, and that's part of the reason
why this is called light weight reliable virtual
memory to indicate that it's light weight in
terms of transaction properties. Now how to make
it really perform well? The first thing is
the strategy that they use for recording changes
to the persistent portion of the virtual memory.
The logging strategy is what is called no
undo/redo value logging. No undo, meaning that we
are creating an undo record of the changes that we're
going to make to virtual memory, but it is not a log
that is persistent on the disk. It is just an in-memory
copy that is kept only for the duration of the transaction,
and at the end of the transaction either it commits or
aborts. We throw away that undo copy that we created. On
the other hand, redo is the log that you create. First
of all, in memory of the data structure in RBM, and
we commit those data structure to memory, and
in committing the changes of the redo logs, we
are only writing the new value records of committed
transactions to the log. So, even though the redo
log. Consists of a transaction start and the
changes that you're making, only new value records of
commuter transactions are written to the log. Now this
is the reason you have forward displacements, that a
that we know where to append to the log segment
on the disk there is a in memory version of
the log segment too which you are writing the redo
logs. And once you've written the redo logs, you're flushing
it to the disk. On the disk, you have a
on-disk version of this redo log record for this particular
process, and what you're doing at a commit point is
only writing the new value records of the committed transactions.
A detail of the log segment. So we are only appending to that log segment the
new changes that have been made within this
transaction. So upon commit, what we need to do
is we have to replace the old value
records in the virtual memory with the new value
records. But this is automatic because the way
LRVM works is that it is created an undo
record of the old value records of that
portion of the virtual address base and all
the changes that the developers making to the
persistence data structures in memory are happening in memory
and therefore replacing the old value records by
the new value records in the virtual memory is
automatic. Only if you abort, you have to
undo the changes. But if you're committing then your
virtual memory is already ready to go in
terms of the changes that are being made
within the transaction. At that point you have
to force the redo log records to the
log on the disc, and as I mentioned earlier, the optimization that's
available in the implementation is to get transactions on the cheap.
In particular, the no restore optimization allows implementation not
to create an in memory undo record. That's
time saved in terms of copying. And that
means better performance for the application. And similarly,
no flush, a commit point tells RBM that
it can write the redo log to the disk lazily. It does not have to block
the process that is making that call, the
end transaction call. And that is an opportunity
again to make that implementation more performance-conscious. So
this lazy commitment of course has its downside,
there is this window of vulnerability that I
mentioned, and that is, there is a time window
between n transaction and the point at which
the redo log has been forced to the disc
and this is the window of vulnerability and
if The system caches within this time, then we
have lost the redo records that we wrote to in memory. And that is important to
understand, that there is a price you pay,
in order to get this flexibility and performance
in the implementation. You can see that this,
redo log data structure, allows traversal in both
directions. And this is for flexibility in implementing
the RVM runtime. In particular writing to the
on disk version of this redo log,
having these forward displacements allows you to know
where exactly you want to append to
the existing redo log record from the changes
that are being done in this particular
transaction, and being committed at this point in
time. And similarly the diverse displacements are
helpful in traversing the log record during recovery.